I gotta believe oh hey brush they didn't
see it
welcome to parappa the rapper - it took
us three years to finish for a / - one I
hope you savor this moment because next
part is not gonna be adding until three
years I'm excited as [ __ ] to play this
you feel it you feeling the music I hope
they fixed their problem set the first
one half but goddamn I enjoyed the first
one what is this super mario [ __ ]
hell
beard burgers and / up a town tradition
this game is it was 90s [ __ ] game
ever this game is a comic sense of
videogames [ __ ] I can't tell if mine
say injected like LSD inside me or bring
on the ketchup don't forget the keys how
did I miss don't forget to cheese me on
the message
you know what I want I have our
traditional bad burger me too
what the [ __ ] is that burger what
noodles noodles again no more noodle
burgers I got a B that is right yeah I
am in the house the best burgers and
good you got you got a heat okay and
tossed you got a cook [ __ ] good bridge
cut what is happening cut the lettuce
getting better so the drinks cook those
burger patties over
cut the letters get the cheese those my
hands my ass swing the kitchen what I'm
talking about those buggers right now
that was [ __ ] Swedish a check this is
where the phenomena known as
neutralization is taking place owner
ization being served in this town is
turning into noodles
oh [ __ ] sale boy that is nearly my night
man here goes oh no no what in the world
happened here where's dad
well let's wait for him hmm oh my god
holy [ __ ]
that is my [ __ ] ass
come on give me the beat give me that
sick beat cake cake dick ass dick
welcome to another episode
oh my god is in the area please be the
onion there eye to eye each other's
eyeball yes put the kids to bed because
this is strictly for adults oh mama
oh my my young children redux what's
okay did he say he said it was only for
a dog run new roman and he started young
children by me you will soon enter the
worth of adults adults yeah I know
gotta leave mm-hmm
I'm so excited so excited I just came at
any time you get the room on all right
let's do it
the [ __ ] is that painting
come on let it be a good sign there's
one of a good song yes indeed some yeah
the kick on Saturday means bass door
there are pending always the farm to
make a move this time we get down Isis
love king the big spa nice getting worse
what the [ __ ] man [ __ ] you
getting better getting better
Wow is weird as lyrics what the what am
i doing my friend the [ __ ] are we doing
like so like butter Yama virus your
rubbers what the [ __ ] punchy la bande
big job jump and tweets Kiki wait kick
it Oh Riven rare sake
[ __ ] you do intern what are we doing
to my friend thank you can see what very
smooth they said in a monkey any very
room are you see you next time
much love to you to San say these guys I
love this game I get love this game like
I love my child and I don't have a child
so you can imagine how much I love it
alright brother I hope you enjoyed this
leave it like if you want more leave a
comment if y'all mind yeah my is Oh God
I'm texting with my big [ __ ] sake what
is this what the [ __ ] is going on this
is even a game